- I don't know what this means,
but I feel chuffed right now.
(gentle music)
- Hello everyone.
- Today we're going to try and guess.
- British slang.
- [Woman] Chuffed.
- You just got chuffed, like what.
- I think it means you're
feeling cocky or boastful.
- [Woman] I'm so chuffed about tomorrow.
- I'm so excited for tomorrow.
(ding)
- [Woman] Knackered.
- It's crazy to me how
this is still English.
- This probably sounds so
much cooler with the accent.
- Sleepy.
'Cause I want a nap.
'Cause I'm knackered.
- [Woman] Cuppa.
- Is it a cop?
- Like a cup of tea?
(ding)
Oh, what!
- [Woman] Chin wag.
- Put an N here, it would be chin wang.
- If you go like, is that a chin wag?
- Chin wang.
- It's not wang, it's wag.
- Don't (bleep) with me, chin wag.
- [Woman] I invited my
friends out for a chin wag.
- You invited your
friend out to talk shit.
(ding)
- What.
Oh you got it!
- Yes, 'cause I practice
this, no I'm just kidding.
- Skint.
- Bloody skint.
- The T at the end makes
it sound like you're turnt.
(laughs)
- I'm so skint.
- [Woman] Paul is skint
and can't go out with his mates.
- Oooh, I don't have any money.
(ding)
That's why, I know.
- No deniro.
- [Woman] Leg it.
- I'm not gonna lie, I thought
it said legit at first,
but there's a space.
- Accelerate the car.
- Or it could just mean,
I'm gonna walk there.
- Oh, that sounds correct.
- Run, really?
- Really.
- Yeah!
- Tosser.
- Tosser?
- I'm thinking of a salad, but it's not.
- It's like a douchebag.
(ding)
Like, you're a tosser.
- [Woman] Nicked.
- Ooh, this sounds familiar.
- Isn't that like when you're saving?
- [Woman] He nicked my
bag at the pub last night.
- Stole.
- Stole?
- Swiped it.
- Snatched.
That tosser nicked my bag.
- [Woman] Pissed.
- I'm pretty familiar.
- You're pissing me off, right?
- Is this like a trick question?
- This means you're wasted, drunk.
(ding)
- I think it's so cool, 'cause
it's like the same language
but so many different things
that can come out of it.
- I'm really bad at pronouncing words.
I don't wanna embarrass.
- No do it, please.